bienvenue dans le paf c'est le dernier
pape de la saison comme vous le savez
quand on arrive à la fin d'une saison on
aime beaucoup faire un bilan de ce qui
s'est passé pour nous est donné nous ne
dérogerons pas donc à la règle en
revenant sur quelques uns des événements
que nous avons nous mêmes qu'on monte
ici on se demande aussi nous avons fait
des beaux commentaires ou si ces
commentaires ont changé avec le recul et
avec le temps et puis on parlera aussi
un petit peu d'actualité pour parler de
tous ces sujets stéphane morceaux
bonsoir ou bonjour patrice dois dire
corps petite pensée pour les coureurs du
tour de france qui ont un peu moins
chaud que nous exactement dans cette
vidéo voilà prévenus de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin toujours
vraiment 50
florence mercadé du barreau de
versailles
bonjour bravo encore à radier alors
quand au record dans cette émission
seront pour vous en tenir rigueur
mustapha larbaoui qui est toujours à
l'ordre des pharmaciens ad non plus de
l'ordre ni des mineurs du bundle club de
trappes non plus dans les tno point
transferts en ce moment que c'est
peut-être marqué la période des
transferts mercato on cherche des
trappes
non ça va vous sinon même pas n'ont pas
d'argent c'est juste du troc à la
vanille bonjour patrice bien ça va bien
merci
soyez l'année
universitaire et finit l'année scolaire
touche à sa fin c'est ça partiel terminé
par celle de terminer et régis j'espère
oui résultats dans quinze jours d'accord
vous tiendra au courant la saison
prochaine ça je le dirai et je savais ni
visiteurs évidemment peut-être que dire
enfin de en fin de l'émission pour nous
donner au conseil divisé avec une très
bonne idée alors je vous dis on va
revenir sur un certain nombre
d'événements de l'année mais il ya aussi
des faits d'actualité il ya actuellement
les négociations qui ce qui se passe
avec la grèce entre l'europe et la grèce
où il semble qu'on va arriver
vraisemblablement un accord si cet
accord est ensuite ratifié par les
parlements et les parlements nationaux
notamment le bundestag qui pourraient
faire obstacle
mais voilà la question qui se pose c'est
est ce que vous êtes d'accord est ce
qu'il faut faire des efforts pour que la
grèce reste dans la zone euro
ou est-ce qu'il faut la laisser revenir
au brad est ce que c'est ça la solution
veut commencer
moi je veux bien commencé moi je suis
choqué par l'attitude de type rask dire
que il organise un référendum très bien
très vite parfait tout le monde la
moitié du monde le critique l'autre
moitié est dit que c'est très bien mais
bon peu importe le plus bas de la vie le
référendum a lieu le peuple grec
s'exprime dit non a quand même 65 % je
crois et trois jours après
mais eux même si brasse arrive en europe
en disant voilà on à 65% de nos
compatriotes ont voté non mais je
propose ce contre quoi ils ont voté ils
se il se moque de son peuple se moque de
tous les grecs les grecs être renforcée
des grèves on a voté contre les trois
propositions qu'il a faites
oui mais a failli rien peut renforcer la
table des négociations probablement non
oui enfin je veux dire c'est ça sert à
faire voter les gens fassent est un déni
de démocratie tout le monde était là en
train de dire c'est merveilleux la
démocratie vive les grecs n'ont pas là
c'est un scandale absolu
aucun sens sa valeur sur précisément sur
le référendum
alors c'est un peu vrai que
manifestement ce qu'il est en train
d'accepter correspond à l'exact
contraire de ce pour quoi les grecs ont
voté mais il promet rien une pression
mais alors est un sujet très référendum
et du référendum en général à ce
référendum moi j'ai été assez sympa pas
étonné mais abasourdi par le fait que
beaucoup d'électeurs grecque ne savait
pas s'il fallait facile leur devait s'il
leur fallait voter oui ou non
pourquoi parce que la question va pas
très bien quelle est l actrice est ce
que vous voulez rire assuré dans leurs
robes la zone euro est ce que vous le
plan qui s'est confié qu'elle était plus
beau exactement je dois était donc ce
qui me fait dire si vous voulez mais
peut-être aussi à contre-courant où on
s'extasie devant le référendum on va en
mettre partout en disant ça y est ça va
être démocratique et c'est le jeune
irait peut-être pas jusqu'à dire que le
référendum est en soi un mécanisme anti
démocratique mais pas loin pourquoi
parce que le peuple ne maîtrise pas la
question
la question est entre les mains de ceux
qui ont le pouvoir et qu'en posant les
bonnes questions on peut faire en sorte
d'obtenir les bonnes réponses alors je
ne dis pas que le peuple se trompent
je ne dis pas que les gens sont des
crétins mais en tout cas il faut arrêter
de considérer de considérer ou de
surinterpréter les vertus démocratiques
du référendum parce que le référendum
ça n'est pas la démocratie est ce que
j'ai surtout course est organisée en
moins de huit jours louis aliot est ce
que les grecs allaient l'horizon que
fiabilité de la démocratie cno
visiblement là et pendant vous dire est
ce vous vous disiez est ce que est ce
que vous pensez aux fonctions ce serait
faire l'homme c'est toujours la critique
qu on fait un référendum
c'était une sorte de plébiscite pro ou
autres types race pour lui donner voilà
plus de moyens de négocier moi je pense
que le le fin fond de l'histoire enfin
si tant est qu'on puisse l'identifier
ça n'était pas tant un
un poids pour ses négociations avec le
reste de la zone euro que surtout me
semble-t-il un mécanisme destiné à le
renforcer au sein de sa propre cause
il ya une colline coalition extrêmement
hétéroclites
je crois pas que contrairement à ce
qu'on lit tsipras sein de certaines
plumes soit d'extrémistes invétéré et
c'est un peu plus subtil que ça mais en
tout cas il a dans sa coalition très
hétérogène il a éprouvé quelques
difficultés à faire avancer son point de
vue et le référendum me semble-t-il à
d'abord servi à le légitimer au sein de
sont les premières victimes
moi je pense que c'était pas si ça
dégage par rapport à sa coalition je
pense qu'il est quand même un peu
embarrassé par rapport à son parlement
parce que et par rapport au plan qui
vient de proposer à l'europe c'est parce
que je suis pas ça je pense que c'est
une autre coalition qui va peut-être le
soutenir pour l'autoriser à présenter
son plan au 28 élections anticipées
parce que là il devait et doit
interroger d'abord son parlement pour
être autorisé à présenter le plan un
syndic et c'est pas là peut-être pas la
même coalition qui valent autorisé il va
peut-être aller piocher plus vers les
socialistes et les conservateurs que
vers sa coalition en tout cas d'extrême
gauche
oui va être quand même un peu en
difficulté comme disait jean charles où
il propose un plan qui correspond à ce
que demandent les créanciers sauf que il
va aussi continuer à solliciter une
baisse de
une baisse de la dette alors par rapport
à la question de sueur est ce qu'il faut
que la grèce sorte ou pas de l'europe
je pense que leur offre de vins de
l'euro et après on verra sur europe 1
mais de la zone euro je pense que
l'europe ait une vraie responsabilité
dans la situation de la grèce parce que
l'europe est intervenu je pense trop
tard trop peu et de manière beaucoup
trop rigide si syriza et en pouvant je
pense que c'est aussi grâce à une
position psychorigide notamment de
l'allemagne par rapport à un refus de
négocier de négocier sur la dette donc
syriza et par là par hasard non plus un
rapport à la position de l'europe et je
pense que les européens prennent un peu
de chance puisque là on voit quand même
dit rétropédalage très rapide sur cette
semaine voire même merkel qui commençait
à dire comment on pourra peut-être
négocier sur la dette
après voir qu'elle le fasse passer elle
allait maintenant je gagne ça se passe
il ya là un or voilà un enjeu national
elle aussi qui est parent qui est pas
mince et je pense qu'il aurait il ya
vrai par rapport à l'échelle de l'europe
dans cette dans la gestion de cette
problématique là il ya une
responsabilité je pense que les hormones
dans ce cas présent
l'échec de l'europe il est surtout on
pose la question de savoir si la grèce
va sortir de leurs appels n'auraient
jamais dû y rentrer c'est ça le vrai
problème elle avait un pied en lançant
rien mais son jeu original mais oui dont
médiapart regard de la banque l'a
peut-être que les états européens
dépensent à merkel peut-être hollande
aurait mieux fait de soutenir le
précédent gouvernement grec plutôt que
de la culée encore faire des réformes
difficiles à passer pour les gens et de
favoriser le micro si price au plus
juste j'ai juste un tout petit dernier
point je pense que ce serait une
catastrophe si elle sortait de la zone
euro et ensuite je sais pas de l'europe
mais en tout cas géographiquement il ya
vraiment un point les géopolitiquement
il ya un point de fragilité parce que là
tous les migrants pouvoir passer et il
ya un véritable enjeu par rapport à 1
l'a d'abord à la russie est de 2 par
rapport à des problématiques islamiste
est donc un enjeu géopolitique kiné qui
n'est pas mars
si on
lâcher la grèce mostafa beaucoup de
choses ont été dites est vrai cette
femme il ya un petit moment maintenant
c'est limite si on va pas en faire une
overdose de graisse en l'occurrence mais
je pense que le référendum
patrick le référent fait personne n'a
jamais la comprimer sa tournée surtout
autour de la cravate et vous pour ou
contre la cravate et je vois qu autour
de cette table on est trois à voir
répondre commencé que j'aurais bondi
alors oui au référendum et on est trois
à voir tenait plus sérieusement c'est
vrai que il ya un peu de ça quand même
c'est à dire que on dit que l'habit ne
fait pas le moine
simplement c'est un peu ça que ça m'a
donné comme c'était assez curieux la
manière dont ce garçon a été traité on a
l'impression qu'il y avait un garçon qui
traitait le sujet après tout il est grec
qui connaît bien le sujet connaît bien
son sujet connaît bien la méthode et
l'angle qu'il a entrepris de prendre
dans son pays vis-à-vis des institutions
mais il ya eu un traitement très
particulier à la fois de la personne et
en même temps du parti qu'il représente
voir des dangers qu'il représente c'est
à dire ce côté voilà vindicative ce côté
revendiqué un exemple ce côté on va dire
quasi anar et donc c'est j'ai presque
l'impression qu'on était dans le coup
d'après c'est à dire au parlement
européen c'était le seul qui était
habillé de la manière c'est celui qui
parlait de cette manière et on pensait
presque au coude après c'est à dire des
hommes politiques comme ça on n'en veut
par des partis politiques comme cela on
n'en veut pas sauf que en europe
c'est de plus en plus vrai qu'on les
retrouve à la fois en grèce le retrait
d'israël
on trouve en france il y en a aucun qui
par sa grand mère vous vérifierez c'est
le signe distinctif
d'où le nom jour apporte un double
référendum
et pour monter d'un cran également moi
ce qui m'a plu dans cette dans cette
période et c'est pas fini jusqu'à ce
jusqu'à maintenant on sait pas trop mais
je pense qu'on peut dire sérieusement
qu'il y aura un accord qui sera trouvée
pour une raison simple c'est que il ya
eu il ya une envie de faire rentrer la
grèce pour de grands principes
simplement on en avait parlé moyen voire
on n'a même pas vérifié mais les grands
principes étaient là il faut que la zone
géographiquement européenne soit
constitué par tous les pays qui la
constituent l'eurozone c'est encore
autre chose et l'euro c'est encore un
autre niveau
je pense qu'on n'a pas eu les moyens de
notre politique mais la politique
consiste à dire on veut nos zones
géographiques géostratégique
celle-ci on l'avait on va y revenir et
ça va nous coûter mais par contre le
débat m'a intéressé parce que qu'on
parle jamais suffisamment d'europe on a
parlé pendant a beaucoup parlé à parle
pas les prises non mais quand même mal
alors les égoïsmes nationaux
c'est ça et c'est là où je me rends
compte que finalement on parle jamais
d'europe mais quand on en parle on se
rend compte qu'il n'ya pas d' européen
c'est à dire que chaque pays se
retrouvera sans nationalisme chaque
parti politique et on voit bien que les
extrêmes ont des solutions extrêmement
simple que ce soit à l'extrême gauche da
soit l'extrême droite c'est juste sur le
dégager extrêmement simple il faut
sortir de l'euro je crois qu'on est même
à un moment on se pose tous la question
de savoir est finalement et si l'euro on
ne vais pas arrêter
voilà donc ce sujet de la grèce et de sa
dette pose le sujet réellement de
l'europe
moi j'aimerais qu'on en parle beaucoup
plus souvent parce que je ne serai pas
là un européen convaincu
mais c'est très compliqué d'arriver à
une solution qui sera à terme bonne pour
toute la zone pour tous pour les grecs
comme pour les français puisque je suis
pas convaincu qu'on parle pas de la
dette française dans très peu de temps
oui surtout qu'on demandait on demandait
quand même un moment à la grèce de faire
quatre et demi pour cent de r2
budget excédentaire alors que nous on
n'arrive pas à faire 3 % de déficit
corrigée à la moindre niches fiscales et
français quand même
alors après on peut s'étonner qu'ils
pressent à pouvoir m'enfin c'est faudra
pas qu'on l'aimé
pour compléter ces vrais les propos
l'union européenne je pense qu'à elle et
elle est là pour vous y croyez vous
alors oui oui oui
en tant que jeune en plus non mais c'est
vrai qu'à l'école en plus non mais c'est
important à l'école on nous sensibilise
il ya avant il y avait chez lui comme on
appelle ça le bon un truc civique et
puis maintenant c'est orienté anglais
vraiment sur l'europe pour créer un
sentiment d'appartenance à l'europe et
se sentir plus européen que français
italiens espagnols ou je ne sais quoi
mais au delà telle union européenne avec
tous les échanges marchands qui ont été
mis en place
on est là en fait pour résister faire
une coalition contre la pression
américaine dans un premier temps c'était
s'appuient aujourd'hui c'est contre la
pression chinoise russe etc
je pense vraiment que si la grèce comme
le disait très bien florence tout à leur
sort de l'europe nécessairement ça va
donner cette mauvaise idée à bon nombre
de pays on va être face à un éclatement
européen et joe géopolitiquement ce
serait catastrophique je pense qu
économiquement la taffetas il y en
aurait pas qu'un quoi donc je pense que
ce serait ce serait dramatique
le film n'est pas terminée pour autant
je pense qu'on va céder effectivement on
va trouver
on a fait durer parce qu'il faut faire
passer le message les godillots temps
perdu mais globalement le film n'est pas
terminée prenons ensemble c'est que le
problème n'est pas résolu
non en grèce mais à mon avis ça va faire
tache d'huile ailleurs parce que là où
je rejoins jean charles c'est
qu'effectivement l'idée selon laquelle
on cèderait aux grecs
pourquoi ne pas céder aux italiens aux
portugais et aux irlandais et à d'autres
j'ai envie de dire aux français en plus
à l'idée on a l'idée du front national
ou de hulu ou de la gauche c'est ce
serait de dire mais finalement sans la
dette tous les pays aurait des excédents
primaires donc horde est donc un budget
équilibré à côté de l'ademe finalement
la solution est trouvée en grèce sur la
trouille dans tous les pays de la même
façon donc c'est pas fini parce qu'à mon
avis il y aura une revendication de la
droite extrêmement attendre l'extrême
gauche keira dans ce sens donc c'est
compliqué mais je pense qu'on a par
chance que vous avez raison de dire que
la situation économique des pays est
très différente dit tout bas parce que
jean luc nadal n'est pas là mais on a
augmenté le même de fonctionner et puis
et puis il ya beaucoup toujours dans les
associations dans les collectivités
locales qui sont d'une manière détournée
de fait de créer du chef de la la
fonction subventionné alors avant de
passer à la nôtre spectre des événements
on a traité ici même peut-être un mot
sur la sur la pétition de denis tillinac
signé notamment par nicolas sarkozy
touche pas à mon église
allez faut préserver les sentinelles de
marque française décrit-il ouais je
n'aurai qu'un mot enfin une phrase belle
pétition c'est l'idée ils vont rappeler
à l'arrivée writer de rappeler que voilà
dalil boubakeur avait déclaré ce micro
europe 1 et bfm je ne sais plus quel
média que pourquoi ne pas transformer
les églises vides en mosquée
alors après il a probablement faut
paraît-il rétropédaler mais enfin je
pense que ce personnage est suffisamment
intelligent et rompu aux arcanes d'un
modèle est un peu comment oui à l'avenir
est là et que donc aussi là s'il a dit
ça c'est qu'il a une idée derrière la
tête c'est pas un type qui est fait son
de sa première télé et qui tout d'un
coup on se trompe donc il l'a fait il
l'a fait exprès dans quel but exactement
je ne sais pas moi c'est plutôt un type
que je trouve
séduisant intellectuellement etc mais je
là je trouve le truc parlement a peu
pervers et puis au delà de ça on n'a pas
fait de sondage précis sur la question
je pense qu'avant qu'il est cette idée
saugrenue
le front national est à 25% je pense que
là on ferait un sondage le front
national doit être à 30-35 % et que
chaque joueur qui va chaque jour qui
passe le front national monte grâce à
des stupidités pareil parce que c'est
absolument irréalisable comme disait
florence tout à l'heure enfin hors
antenne pour les auditeurs et
téléspectateurs mais la majorité des
églises vides sont dans les campagnes où
il n'y a pas besoin de mosquées
donc de toute façon l'idée est stupide
ne vous êtes pas frapper parce que en
effet boubakeur a dit ça mais enfin
personne ne l'a fait repris crois pas
elle était tombée aussi aussi vite que
donne envie de fil de la vie et non et
est-ce qu'ils avaient besoin d'aller
faire une pétition pour un comme si
c'était un projet de loi oui parce que
la réalité parce que ce n'est jamais ces
choses là ne sont jamais dit par hasard
donc quand on dit ça c'est qu'on a une
idée derrière la tête
mais si on réagit pas aux dix bagues
with jeudi sa surface et qui lance la
pétition est une idée derrière la tête
aussi bien sur ses gardes
alors c'est ça qui alors gelé dire
gênant c'est pas gênant du tout
simplement
il ya en premier truc qu'on peut dire
c'est que la question de disponibilité
de viol de lieux de culte pour les
musulmans français en france se pose
c'est indigne parfaitement indigne d'une
république laïque qui est quand même
censé article 1er de la loi du 9
décembre 1905 la liberté de conscience
et la liberté des cultes de d'acculer
des gens à aller pratiquer le culte de
leur choix dans des parkings ou dans des
garages dans les rues dans des gymnases
etc
c'est pas digne ça c'est pas bien soin
et je pense pas que ça favorise en plus
il approche modérée 2
de la religion quelle qu'elle soit et de
l'islam en particulier pour ce cas là le
second de la seconde chose que je
voulais dire c'est que le recteur
boubakeur a suggéré ça alors c'est vrai
dans le cadre d'une interview j'étais en
voiture je l' ai je lu et entendu ça m'a
pas choqué outre mesure je me suis un
peu j'ai un peu regardé après alors ça
se fait ça c'est fait ça se fait donc
certaines communes de france alors c'est
vrai que plus en zone rurale il ya
plutôt pas besoin mais parfois il ya eu
une conjonction favorable et notamment à
graulhet dans le tarn je crois bon
diable afin pas seulement là et ehoud
vers l'empiré du sol et les choses se
passent se passe très bien
ce sont les autorités c'est la
hiérarchie catholique qui a suggéré de
procéder à ce genre de comment dirais-je
de pratiquer des charges enfin voilà le
don d'hébergement alors c'est vrai que
la configuration des églises en lieu de
culte musulman en mosquée ben ça se fait
pas comme ça mais enfin arrêtons aussi
les raccourcis permanent qui consiste à
dire ça y est on va raser les églises on
va construire des mosquées avec des
minarets grand comme la mosquée personne
ne dit c'est la pétition place à
l'opération dis simplement eu comme vous
le dit très justement transforme une
église en mosquée ces masques et tous
les vitraux c'est enlever les statuts
c'est le gars et c'est un changement au
peuple ce qu'on peut être catholique ou
pas catholique
on peut pas nier le fait que les églises
sont relativement je vis et font partie
du patrimoine français à son canon jolie
les églises ne sont pas tous les autres
on les détruit parce que c'est des
charges très lourdes pour les communes
ont peu plus les entretenir
enfin enchères je ne soyez pas de
mauvaise foi on sait très bien que la
majorité des églises sont jolies et sont
anciennes et puis techniquement bon
c'est vrai sur les 35 premières heures
tu vois là c'est le cas maintenant
et puis roulée transit auront les
transforme en hôtel alors en discothèque
moi je suis jamais allé dans les
discothèques dans une ancienne église
mais ça serait en revanche je suis allé
dans un hôtel construit dans une église
dans une ancienne église ça choque
personne
c'est moins choquant c'est pesant c'est
pas un as et pas un abandon une drôlerie
qui sème le vent une affaire du commerce
que de la religion mais moi ça me choque
qu'une religion se substituer une autre
je suis choqué lorsque tu vas à cordoue
gc sophie à cordoue en l'occurrence
lorsqu'il ya eu l'inquisition hop
il avait repris la mosquée qui elle-même
en fait avait été récupérée sur une
ancienne
on parle donc bien les unes plus d'une
sorte de guerre larvée et de lutte
terrible entre deux religions parce que
les exemples que tu cite des exemples
que site stéphane c'est quand même ça
c'est quand même pas passé dans la bonne
humeur la plus joyeuse
donc si c'est ça l'idée je vois pas
l'intérêt vous savez moi je rejoins jean
charles sur un point c'est que autant je
je dirais pas touche pas à mon église je
dirais touche pas mon symboles sont
globalement c'est vrai que je suis
effrayé tout le temps comme ça qu'on
s'attaque à des symboles que ça soit les
synagogues ça soit les geeks sur les
mosquées
c'est effrayant et je pense que là le
propos de boubakeur avait à mon avis une
signification et c'est toujours pareil
quand on veut regarder le côté positif
des choses ou la noirceur des choses je
pense pas qu'il ait voulu dit il faut
prendre d'assaut les églises parce que
moi je te répondrais très sincèrement
combien y aurait un catholique aurait
besoin de son église dans laquelle il
veut prier il n'y a pas la transformer
pour qu'il soit sera combien mais ils
n'auraient qu'un donc finalement c'est
ouais touchez pas au symbole c'est en ça
que je vous rejoins jean charles mais je
pense que ce qui a été dit également moi
c'est son côté positif qui m'intéresse
c'est que ça ressemble aussi à l'idée
selon laquelle les musulmans vont dans
les églises
il est fréquente ils y vont je vais le
24 au soir régulièrement quand je peux à
la messe de minuit
on ne rentre parce qu'il ya ce côté ces
discussions autour de l'islam de
l'islamisation et le caractère un peu à
peu un peu musclé crème
il ya cette idée selon lesquelles on
pourrait pas vivre ensemble vivre et les
uns à côté des autres
les mosquées elles sont fréquentés par
des musulmans mais pas simplement et les
églises
les musulmans peuvent y aller puisque là
il est reconnu
entre guillemets dans la religion je
suis pas un spécialiste pas me lancer là
dedans mais je crois que c'est cette
idée là selon laquelle vos églises si
elles sont vides si elles sont vides ce
qu'on pourrait pas les utiliser
maintenant si elles ne sont pas pareils
on n'a pas y rentrer de force il ya
quand même une institution la loi et
deuxièmement les musulmans vont dans les
aiguilles auquel cas ça veut dire aussi
il ya une communauté qui parle à une
autre communauté et c'est pas tout de
suite en disant je suis scandalisée faut
pas qu'ils y rentrer ben s'ils peuvent
centrer mais simplement moi je serais
d'accord avec vous s'il faut la
transformer mais il a transformé les
vitres alors c'est de là qu'est ce qu'un
lieu de culte
huit villes ce n'est pas une atteinte à
tout les rôdeurs séance à qui si
vraiment ça choque personne
le fait est qu'ils aient personne en
tant qu'ils sont utilisés mais je la
retirerais à personne c'est un symbole
qui m'intéresse si je pense que ça pose
surtout une question c'est un de moins
en moins de pratiquants catholiques et
ça ça pose le doigt là dessus en france
on a alors que les pays chrétiens sauf
que la désertification des églises donc
de moins en moins de pratiquants
catholiques aient besoin d'eux mais
c'est pas aussi il ya eu des études set
il a chuté sur ip etc et ce genre dans
la peur et l'eonia pas l'accord eleonora
moment donné si on a qu'un qui va la
glisse elle est là il y va c'est son
église on peut on peut prier sans nom ce
que je veux dire c'est que si folle
corrélé au nom c'est là où on va tomber
dans il ya plus de musulmans ou telle
région nous quand même plus de mosquées
ou quelqu'un va pouvoir acquisitions et
les églises pour balada une église si
maintenant le dialogue s'instaure et tu
y as caissargues l'intérieur c'est comme
ça qu'il a entendu et c'est la fixation
des scandaleuses comme d'habitude je
veux la paix de pardon mais on peut pas
réquisitionner une église en pour
l'affecter à votre une théorie et c'est
la loi est très bien fait la loi du
navet en 1905 pour qu'on intéressant que
ce mouvement assez mal parce que on lit
l'article 2 avant de lire l'article 1er
la réalité un article de garanties de
protection de la liberté pour chacun
d'avoir avions tout donnant à voir
aucun et donc le droit et de ce point de
vue là très bien fait les autorités ne
peuvent pas réquisitionner une église
il faut l'accord de la hiérarchie en
place de la mongie catholicisme au xixe
et sans l'accord de l'arrêté des
religieuses mais rien ne se fait auquel
cas il s'agit pas d'avenir ici ciel
juste enfin dernière chose qui me choque
avec nous ce que vous dites tous les
quatre faux pas mustapha mais stéphane
et et florence et la pétition est
scandaleuse des quelque chose ne vous
plaît pas c'est scandaleux c'est à dire
que les gens peuvent s'exprimer ils ont
pas tort on peut signaler dans le ciel
vous disiez tout à l'heure avec des
arrières pensées boubakeur on peut
penser qu'il ya aussi derrière moi ce
qui me gêne c'est défendre c'est très
bien qu'ils aient des pétitions mais ce
qui me gêne c'est que moi quand je vois
cette pétition j'ai un peu le sentiment
d'être pris pour un crétin c'est à dire
que ont saisi comme ça au pied levé un
événement on les dit on lui fait dire ce
que la bible à terre s'il n'a pas dit
par puis on sur un tas de machines il
est pour des considérations déclaration
il a fait cette déclaration n'a pas
inventé et une vous l'avez entendu les
messieurs récurrence il l'a dit seul
salon représente pratiquement que lui on
va dire mais là la pétition doivent y
être c'est qu'ils sont nombreux les
matières premières donc ils sont
nombreux à vouloir faire passer un sujet
qui pour le coup c'est boubekeur chéri
n'était plus un événement éventuellement
il y aurait eu un représentant de
l'église ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que la france non non non pas du tout
c'est que la france c'est comme le
disait très justement mustapha il faut
des lieux de culte pour les musulmans il
faut des lieux de culte pour les pour
les juifs il faut des véhicules pour les
catholiques
après on peut pas nier c'est ça me
paraît une évidence qu'il ya un passé
catholique et que les églises ventre ans
ne sont plus légitimes entre guillemets
que les que les mosquées après c'est
tout à fait désolant que les musulmans
sont obligés de prier dans les reins
dans un garage dans une soupente bien
évidemment mais je
vois pas l'intérêt de cette provocation
ultime en train de dire ben voilà vous
avez un petit peu de mal avec votre
religion en ce moment les églises sont
vides on va s'installer chez vous je
dire c'est un truc mais scandaleux cc
c'est un truc terrible c'était
exactement ce que ça voulait dire c'est
un ballon d'essai et heureusement que
cette pétition existent pour dire qu'il
ya des gens que ça choque et parmi les
signataires on a beaucoup mais enfin il
ya comme les autres républiques 6,2 en
seine saison deux anciens ministres
simone ya aussi finkielkraut qu'elle est
pensée remet un cercueil c'était son
rôle de signer sa wii garant des cultes
oui mais bien sûr si on roulait les
anciens matériels vous passez votre
temps tous à dire que les hommes
politiques ne font pas leur boulot qu'on
ils ont pas l'eau là où on les attend et
là c'est quand même un vrai problème la
preuve c'est que l'on ce qu'on se pose
un petit peu et qu'un homme politique de
premier plan contre la précis qu'on
n'apprécie pas il a été président de la
république ils aspirent à le redevenir
que c'est cet homme politique et un avis
sur la question ça me paraît
indispensable
moi j'en ai marre des gens qui n'ont pas
d'avis ils sont tout le temps en train
de dire c'est pas grave on verra non on
ne verra pas ses graves et se trouve
très bien que vous ayez votre avis j'ai
le mien sarkozya siens et c'est
indispensable sur votre avis est tout à
fait légitime en leur entier mais
simplement on dit pas qui fait pas son
boulot il peut faire un boulot qui fait
mal en même temps donc les politiques
font pas leur boulot si il fait son
boulot minerai qui nous font mal ou plus
ou moins bien parce qu'il est pas sur
cette question à mon avis peuple sur
cette question à mon avis trompe il veut
être président faut rassembler plus que
divisé ses clients sont là on va revenir
contre le pape le pape lui était dans
son rôle en disant par exemple que les
chrétiens dans le monde étaient
persécutés qui est même un génocide etc
il est dans son rôle je crois qu'il
disait il a une parole très forte et je
le soutiens encore dire je suis souvent
d'accord avec françois avec françois le
pape est ce que j'en sors
on en est c'est dedans on aborder
évidemment on a commencé à aborder l'un
des sujets sur lesquels on s'était
interrogé cette année c'était et je me
souviens des premières émissions ont
parlé du retour de certaines qui n'était
pas encore avérée à ce moment là est ce
qu'il va revenir ce qui va revenir
donc là il est revenu ou la question est
simple à ce que le retour de sarkozy
c'est une réussite ou un échec
je commencerai par dire que c'est il ya
sur un point scénario site sur un point
dans le puits des affaires je pensais
qu'il serait plombé ce garçon par ses
affaires en tous les cas supposé par le
corps et l infini alors c'est en ça que
je dis je ne sais pas si c'est fini mais
je trouve j'avais le siège à côté là moi
j'avais le sentiment qu'ils revenaient
quasiment que pour ça c'était un
sentiment personnel quasiment que pour
ça parce que c'est pour çà et là bas
qu'on ne parle plus des avatars qui
étaient chargés sur ce point là j'ai
l'impression qu'on en parle beaucoup
moins qu'on ne parlerait d'autres sujets
pour le reste yves est revenue il est
effectivement très présent mais à chaque
fois c'est sur un une position
extrêmement dur
il est sur des positions que je que je
qualifierais mois de clivante et on
retrouve le sarko qu'on a connu
qu'on a connu dans les premières
commandes bien avant même qu'il soit
président en 2007 donc j'ai l'impression
que chassez le naturel il revient au
galop
mais il y avait un but avoué ou non
avouée plutôt qui était celui de masquer
toutes ses affaires et enfin revenir au
pouvoir mais encore une fois
probablement pour rassembler son camp
mais je suis pas sûr que ça soit une
stratégie on a d'autres qui ont choisi
d'autres
juppé n'a pas choisi d'être clivant tout
de suite d'autres n'ont pas choisi cette
méthode
alors je sais pas ça va arriver réussir
mais c'est un retour mais c 17 un film
qu'on a déjà vu c'est vrai j'ai
l'impression de l'axé que sur près de
nous à venir non j'ai l'impression
surtout qu ils s'attendaient vraiment un
retour triomphal is it annoncé comme ça
il a dit on m'a pris pour sa gueule non
j'ai surtout l'impression que peu sont
ceux à l'attendre beaucoup s'en exaspère
et il fait ce qu'il peut quoi il fait ce
qu'il peut pour résister mais je pense
qu'il ira pas bien loin
parce que je crois que les gens vraiment
on en fait le tour les fortes
personnalités comme ça toujours
omniprésente sur devant de la scène qui
parle très excessive à un moment donné
on s'en lasse il je pense qu'il est ce
que c'est ce dont il a besoin
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on voudra en 2017 florence
à moi je le trouve alors en dehors du 7
ans je ne trouve beaucoup moins bon que
ce qu'il a pu être dans sa campagne
c'est dans je trouve voilà il est
excellent et là pour le coup je le
trouve beaucoup moindre je le trouve qui
barrent l'extrême droite de manière qui
choque personnellement et donc pour
enfin de ce que je peux en voir tout
c'est plutôt un échec les quais fait les
gens l'attend pas autant que sage s'est
d'abord laissé la preuve d'ailleurs qui
partant à l'extrême droite
il a conscience aujourd'hui que c'est la
seule carte à jouer s'il veut passer il
faut rallier l'extrême droite
donc c'est bien la preuve qu'il sait
qu'il n'arrive pas son corps et pour les
primaires et ça va être ça va être des
militants qui vont voter probablement
fin il y aura peut-être des simples et
le stand up qui lui va super bien par
contre c'est un sac il a réussi son coup
je trouve c'est un vrai retour les fans
de garde je garde jean charles pour la
fin du mois de deux choses savoir s'il a
réussi ou pas son retour en général vous
savez après on sera oui c'est bien mais
voilà il est candidat c'est dévié belle
fait brûler puis puis 6,6 en 2010 cet
essai les rayures de mes pas et puis la
seconde chose c'est que moi je en effet
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a montré
qu'il avait un talent politique assez
assez peu commun qui a su le montrer
franchement sa tournée triomphale
enfin rappelle je sais plus quel était
le nom de cette tournée de théâtre de
boulevard qui tournait en province enfin
c'est pas péjoratif d'ailleurs ce qu'il
déplace pas les foules
enfin c'est là peut-être je dis
d'ailleurs il ya très longtemps et
c'était c'était très bien mais c'est
enfin cette ce niveau cc c'est le
comique troupier fait c'est gourmand
ça c'est même franchement enfin ils me
font rire que lui et la cour qu'il ya
autour de lui alors que reste-t-il enfin
moi je pense qu'il suit à nadine morano
et
et bon subtilité parfois m'échappe enfin
je ne juge pas très bien je pars fin mai
mais je leur le coup il n'a pas encore
dit mais j'ai changé parce que ça
combien de fois et il dit en jeu c'est
pas mal à les changer mais je trouve
qu'il a pas changé et est finalement oui
mais c'est du déjà vu
moi c'est de la rif c'est de la mauvaise
heure et diffuseur mais vous avez la
zone dire qu'il faut attendre avant de
donner un jugement d'effectifs jean
charles marziani êtes déçu par l'autre
obligé de reconnaître de ce retour est
sûrement moins facile qu'il l'espérait
et qu'on pouvait le qu'on pouvait le
souhaitez et éventuellement il a fait de
grosses erreurs c'était c'est de
continuer maintenant il a stoppé mais là
contenu beaucoup trop longtemps c'est
cette course au cash ton dans les pays
du monde à prendre des centaines de
milliers d'euros enfin c'était ça
c'était ridicule
il a il a effectivement que commis un
certain nombre d'erreurs après moi je
skie pas ce qui me choque là dedans
c'est que comme le dit très justement
stéphane c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour
savoir s'il réussit pas c'est simplement
plus difficile que prévu c'est une
certitude
ensuite ce qui me choque beaucoup c'est
le propos de sephora c'est que dès que
dès que quelqu'un n'est pas à gauche et
n'est pas au centre est juste à droite
on l'accuse d'être d'extrême droite je
mets au défi quiconque de me dire qu'est
ce qui est vraiment d'extrême droite ont
des trucs de sarkozy qu'est-ce qui est
d'extrême droite ans que dans ce cas les
sarkozy nommé si vous avez 10 à bombay
et flore parce que l'autre signaux
your mind relationnel je voudrais jura
n'est que la somme est une app édition
lundi quand on vient de parler avant ce
n'est pas que ces extrêmes de rapper
signal
c'était donc pour vous dès qu'on dit
choqué et inquiet de la montée le sait
la pièce club et qu'on est inquiet le
fait qu'ils parlent beaucoup plus de
l'islam on aimait passer le chômage et
parce que c'est le sujet c'est un sujet
qui terrorise les gens mais bien sûr que
c'est que d'être conscient que les
français sont inquiets de de ce
renouveau religieux de cette montée de
l'islamisme de 2 des paroles que vous
trouvez anodine de dates dalil boubekeur
qui dit transformant les aigus aimé
connaître ça ça serait méconnaître le
tissu français ce serait très dommage ce
n'est pas d'être d'extrême droite alors
que c'était fabuleux ce qu'avait dit il
ya quelques années
si jean marie le pen dit que le ciel est
bleu comme si les hommes arrivaient à
peine le pen qui l'a dit il faut pas
dire que le ciel est bleu
bon il ya de temps en temps peut-être
des choses bien on va bien cinq ans avec
juppé ou avec des solutions qui donne
sont des solutions qui récupère du front
national c'est injuste de l'émoi
inscrits près du sales draps du centre
mission des problématiques mais c'est sa
sélection débat la nationalité c'est
l'extrême droite donc en fait tout débat
tout débat un peu cuit vendée où la
sélection départ du français de souche
quand tu vois ça s'inscrit dans ce sens
mais lille ne se refait pas on peut on a
le droit de se poser des questions quand
relation mais non seulement l'armée jean
chamoin mon avis ce que je ressens en
vous écoutant c'est que vous avez parlé
du tissu français mais je voudrais pas
drapier vous même dans un espèce des
tofs mais non mais des tops du français
par excellence tourné il ya des trucs
connaissance français venant de
différentes sensibilités donc le
français n'est pas celui simplement
serait l'un incarnant le tissu le
français on en fait partie ont pris part
au moins dans ces quelques fibres
moi j'ai une vraie fibre républicaine et
citoyenne
et pour le coup je l'espère et pour le
coup et pour le coup jean charles est un
genre de tentatives aujourd'hui je
voudrais prendre au moins 7 cette
position le kiki qu'il aime tant la
talentueuse que des palais jean charest
peut te disais aussi que mon serment par
le cas non mais ça c'est toujours la
force des jambes pour être un type halde
pour six autres étaient pas l'extrême
droite alors on n'aurait pas le droit
d'en parler mais on n'est pas obligé
mais parce que cette identité française
on allongeait va voir ce que c'est
comment on n'a pas dit oui et alors là
qu'on peut traiter des gens comme moi
j'aimerais remercier à quel moment on
pourra le faire je me juste ça prenons
rendez vous verrez lors en 2019 on sait
tous que c'est la défense de droits si
on a le droit mais c'est plus souvent
est ce que ce que vous êtes au portant
sa hausse à des réponses chaque ce sont
les réponses qui sont apportées parce
que poser le débat est posé la question
c'est tout à fait légitime mais c'est
après les réponses qui sont données par
nicolas sarkozy qui sont des rêves mais
est-ce qu'ils sont qui je suis d'accord
mais ça va ça va être pareil on devra
les programmes on n'a pas le droit de
parler de toby ramos et ça c'est pas le
jeu de l'extrême mois taubira qui ce
matin encore déclare dans dans society
qu ele pour aménager la vie des
délinquants les peines et c'est qu'elle
n'a pas peur de choquer etc
mais on n'a pas vraiment parlé j'imagine
ce qu'on va dire que je suis d'extrême
droite qu'est-ce que je ne suis pas tout
à fait d'accord avec toi politiques de
tous bords et si tu donnes extrêmement
narcose il le fera reparler de justice
moi qui trouvais la justice c'est
l'extrême droite
pas mal donc en tête mais l'ouvrier
c'est que la droite soit un centre mou
et que le centre mou ça fait le jeu de
françois hollande et de la goule voilà
mais avant avancées ne faut pas avancer
masqué il faut dire je suis socialiste
je ne rêve que d'une chose c'est que
françois hollande repart pour cinq ans
qu'il est radié moi je me suis pris en
charge à l'entrée mais je pense qu'il ya
une confusion parce que l'extrême droite
dont on parle n'est pas seulement
l'apanage du front national donc on ne
qualifie pas sarkozy de front national
quand on parle d' extrême c'est le côté
client c'est revenir en permanence sur
des thèmes prisé par l'extrême droite
voilà c'est de ça dont on parle moins
n'a pas dit qu'il était front national
puisque le front national lui même
des thèses d'extrême droite simplement
quand on rassemble son camp
c'est vrai que je suis un héros non
seulement les gros achats rex est
toujours eu beau être d'accord avec le
front national
or voilà il est toujours opposé à tout
d'accord exactement six ans akis il n'y
a pas de confusion nationale sur les
clivages veut dire ce2 des clivages
naissent des discussions est intéressant
comment ça il faut pas non plus à chaque
fois devraient tous être d'accord sur
tout et est bien on serait dans la rosée
et dans tout ça sinon mon rôle hollande
et non son réseau politiques sont dans
leur rôle que nous ne leur reprochez pas
tout avec de droite et normal soient de
droite c'est dire s'il a toujours
construit sa carrière politique sur le
clivage
oui mais c'est non c'est normal c'est
qu'elle est ce que voilà après la vraie
question qui se pose c'est est ce qu'on
2010 tu es dans un pays qui traverse des
crises depuis des années des années les
gens préféreront quelqu'un qui clivent
ou quelqu'un qui rassemble c'est
peut-être ça sont vos prochains jeux la
vraie question c'est celle là était une
véritable question mais l'hôte ce sera
de savoir le choix quel sera-t-il alors
ce sera entre françois hollande a montré
comme une certaine incapacité est un bon
président en tout cas jusqu'à présent
kipré sarkozy qui ne trouvent pas grâce
à vos yeux
juppé donc est assez curieux et là on
sait pas du tout où il va aller votre
ami berrou qu'il essaye de remonter le
courant comme un saumon et veulent
remonter voilà donc on va avoir un choix
jument extraordinaire seconde erreur se
moquant le saumon du drame s'est terminé
peu après il revend peut-être en juin
lyon qui vient la 51eme sarkozy et de
titres qui critiquent le plus sarkozy
n'aura qu'un jour on m'explique le fion
ce que j'aimerais dans la tête de
françois fillon comment est-ce qu'on
peut être 50 premiers venus de sarkozy
mais pendant cinq ans lorenzi la spa il
a pleuré pour être pour que sarkozy ne
choisissent pas borloo un an et demi
après il l'a supplié sarkozy de garder
et à peine la défaite actée et la csn le
pire critique c'est terrible parce que
c'est enfin on aura un choix incroyable
alors tout ce qu'on sait qu'on a deux
ans on en parle déjà comme si on était
en plein dedans il est vrai problème
sarko chômage je veux dire quand on dort
à ses très proches de suremain défendent
pas plus si c'est que seraient les
plateaux nationaux on n'en parle plus
ici on en parle si la situation du
chômage je pense que ça se saurait mais
il y en a non mais c'est mais qui ont
mis un débat autour de ça moi j'ai eu
l'impression qu'on parlait que pour le
coup de l'islam très longtemps et très
souvent et ça finit toujours par
reboucler sur ce sujet on voit bien qu
amendé on veut on veut mais si on
voulait bien bouclé en permanence le
budget serait plus intéressant autre
sujet il nous reste à peu près une
dizaine de minutes garde un petit peu
tôt pour voilà vos souhaits pour la
rentrée ce sont les attentats du 7
janvier avec cette grande manifestation
je suis charlie pour vous ça a été
c'était un moment recueil bon collectif
un moment fondateur ou plutôt peut-être
une sorte d'illusion collective parce
que c'est vrai que tout le monde a été
je suis charlie le 9 janvier et puis
après c'est retombé un petit peu on a vu
d'ailleurs
j'arrive ont toujours pas un exemplaire
mais on ne sait jamais ma vie 2
je crois qu'il ya vraiment des choses
qu'ils n'auraient peut-être ya l'horreur
absolue du défilé des attentats ça c'est
une chose que moi je différencie
énormément de la suite parce
qu'effectivement je vers l'horreur
attentats il n'y a pas débat
enfin scandale absolu c'est une
boucherie c'était ça n'aurait pas dû
arriver ça ne devrait pas arriver c'est
qu'on ne pouvait pas que le chômage dans
après ce dynamisme assez curieux c'est
toute façon c'est toujours sympathique
parce qu'effectivement on va toujours
clivé cette manifestation monstre elle
avait plutôt sympathique dit pourquoi
pas tout le monde est là on est charlie
ça veut rien dire
pourquoi pas mais il n'en reste rien il
n'en restera rien parce que on est on
est d'une certaine sensibilité que
c'était les zombies catho qui ont
déserté les églises dans le faire des
mosquées les plombs mais ce n'est pas
une certitude mais je ne vois pas ce
qu'il en est ainsi de 2 de se sauver
chargé de ce on est tous charlie je
trouve ça très sympathique moi aussi je
suis charlie mais aimer mais alors bon
ben on est tous
on est tous au ici un service est contre
les attentats ou non mais tous les six
sont nés en tout les souches tous les 6
ans à charlie tous les sous non on n'est
pas charles tous d'abord d'abord il ya
des 2 patrice parce que franchement dans
cette période ayant réellement qui était
absolument exceptionnelle moi je n'ai
vécu comme ça et des moments de
recueillement on en a pas tant que ça
puisque on est plutôt dans des sujets
écrivant on est plutôt agréable sur la
gueule sur les différents sujets il en
avait un rassemblement de gens qui
étaient de droite de gauche
probablement même d'extrême gauche et
peut-être même d'extrême la preuve c'est
que ce moment-là actuellement il en
restera forcément quelque chose parce
que on a avancé d'un pas je crois verts
justement c'est l'idée qu'on se fait des
différentes communautés et ce
rassemblement pour moi il restera au
moins cette chose là c'est ce que je
ressens
alors pardon de parler des quartiers que
je fréquente donc à paris si par
ailleurs on va pas parler de des
banlieues mais c'est vrai que il ya eu à
la fois
ce recueillement et qui laisse à penser
que on est quand même dans un pays
mentalement fort alors qu'on a eu on a
eu un moment donné l'expression d'une
crainte et j'ai même eu peur pour
l'avoir dit ici est ce que les
terroristes n'ont pas gagné
stratégiquement à vouloir qu'on se
divisent pour augmenter les troupes de
ces gens là et finalement les troupes a
priori ne vont pas à gonfler justement
parce qu'il ce rassemblement justement
parce qu'il ya eu ce moment où tout le
monde se rassemble autour d'une cause
autour d'un pays autour d'un drapeau
autour d'un drap et d'un tissu social
qui est important en france n'est que je
trouve que ça c'est peut-être quelque
chose dont on n'a pas le droit de parler
mais enfin statistiquement le nombre de
jeunes qui partent pour le jihad et
constante augmentation gc jalal taubira
et même qui le dit donc voilà si c'est
ça je là je suis un peu perplexe par la
statistique c'est la forme d'allergie la
mairie dire les départs sont incroyables
les statistiques c'est la forme la plus
élaborée du mensonge parce que ce que
vous avez là je ne comprends pas ça veut
dire qu'on était parti à 3000 et c'est
quoi déjà la tirade de nous par femme
parmi les neuf films on va voir mais
franchement dire des choses pareilles
jean-charles il semblerait que depuis le
début
effectivement ce ce désir quasi quasi
quand des révolutionnaires ou mystique
ou ou extrémistes des gens qui sont
partis en masse ça voudrait dire que ce
que vous êtes en train de dire l'un il y
en a eu par mines à peu près
répertoriées aujourd'hui on serait à
combien puisque cette en augmentation
permanente
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'ils sont partis
massivement début et qui a pas la même
maintenant les vrais semble tant mieux
mais sans ça je dis qu'à un moment donné
il ya du fond si c'est vrai que je dis
ça vénus est là on a signé on a on a six
mois de recul et je pense au vu de ce
que je peux voir par mon expérience
d'avocate notamment en matière de droit
social il ya des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus inquiétant qui qui était
un sujet mais pas forcément important
avant le 7 janvier qui devient un sujet
après le 7 janvier je pense que les
terroristes je vais m'expliquer là
dessus les terroristes on a eu une itt
est magnifique sur les manifestations
durent 11 janvier mais qui a des
interstices et que les terroristes ont
réussi à faire à rentrer dans les
interstices et postérieurement au 7
janvier
on voit dans les entreprises qu'il ya eu
alors je peins au niveau entreprise qui
a eu un phénomène de communautarisme
assez fort avec des gens qui se sont
regroupés entre eux et le fait religieux
entre guillemets qui devrait s'emparer
du lac et se soit pas faut pas qu'ils se
sont pas reconnus dans ces
manifestations là et qui se sont
regroupés et là où il n'y avait pas
nécessairement de fait religieux ou que
c'était un bon là où c'était un sujet
mais très mineur dans les entreprises
est devenue un sujet de plus en plus
préoccupant dans les entreprises
postérieurement aux attentats du mois de
janvier
et j'étais un séminaire sur ce sujet là
il ya quelques était une semaine et les
entreprises qui étaient là il ya une
cinquantaine d'entreprises ont tout
témoigné en ce sens en disant après
charlie une a eu des crispations avec
des phénomènes d'opposition au niveau de
l'entreprise avec de plus en plus de
demandes sur le terrain du religieux
alors sans que ce soit quelque chose de
majeur mais où ça a été beaucoup plus
fréquents postérieurement aux attentats
de charlie et je pense que c'est là où
peut-être que les terroristes
réussissent à intégrer
c'est leur but donc unités oui mais
justement c'est intéressant dans six
mois a provoqué aussi comment provoquer
des effets périphériques inquiétant oui
moi je j'ai un souvenir parce que je
n'étais pas en france
à cette époque là à ce moment l'arrivée
non non j'ai hésité de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique et j'ai toujours
l'impression qu'on vit les choses
presque plus intensément lorsqu'on est
vrai que lorsqu'on est sur place et vous
inquiet oui alors je peux vous dire
voilà les télévisions aux états unis
enfin diffusée à la chaîne d'information
diffusée 24h sur 24 la n'avait plus rien
à dire quand il se passait plus rien à
un moment donné mais les choses sont
toujours un peu en réalité augmentée que
celui quand on est éloigné et et d'autre
part je crois florence a raison tout le
monde n'était pas charlie le jeu suisse
à charlie wi il était plutôt répandu
mais c'était pas l'unanimité quand même
et rien que pour cela d'ailleurs il est
intéressant de voir les effets que ça a
produit en effet et puis il ya une
ultime précision je moi je pensais en
vous écoutant au un bouquin de de pierre
rosanvallon qui s'appelle le peuple
introuvables ou il résume les choses en
disant ben voilà le peuple c'est une
espèce d'entité en réalité qui n'existe
pas c'est quelque chose de très abstrait
le peuple c'est une espèce de force à
laquelle on impute des décisions dans
une démocratie mais le peuple ça
n'existe pas mais lorsqu'il ya des
moments où on aperçoit le peuple on
l'aperçoit le dimanche où toutes les
élections ont lieu en même temps là on
le voit un peu le peuple
et puis on le voit dans des moments
comme ça dans des moments un peu aidé
historique
alors je sais pas à ça on le sait après
aussi c'est comme les retours de sarkozy
est ce que ça ce sera un instant
historique j'en sais rien on sera prêt
où on sera peut-être jamais mais c'est
au moins me semble-t-il un instant où on
a aperçu quelque chose qui qu'on
pourrait appeler le peuple
il nous reste 5 minutes peut-être on va
passer aux souhaits
ve pour la rentrée moustapha je pensais
faire un peu de rétrospective parce
qu'une fois jean charles autour de cette
table s'est moqué de l'avion en jupe
oui c'est la rolls on vient de traverser
la manche en 45 minutes avec un avion
électrique donc sabrina et on avance et
le progrès va dans ce sens voilà pour
cela apple voilà qui l'utilisé c'est
tout voilà pour redevenir et voilà bien
démontés d'un boulet voilà pourtant
voilà pour voix la pluie et au val a
pourri fans
ça veut dire qu'il ya effectivement une
évolution comme il ya une évolution
depuis plus de 110 ans depuis blériot
alors aujourd'hui voilà c'était juste
pour les diam's est acceptée en revanche
non moi si j'avais un souhait s'il
serait simplement que les gens fassent
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
attention
encore une fois avec ce soit une période
propice pendant les vacances à
l'alimentation et au tabagisme
voilà c'est juste mon coup de coeur pour
dire que voilà il faut faire attention
profiter de cette période pour bien vous
alimentez mieux vous alimentez et c'est
quand même le premier médicament je
plaide pas en notre faveur mais si si
parce qu'on les retrouve plus tard et en
bonne santé le plus longtemps possible
on les retrouvera de toute façon la
nature fait que les choses se dégradent
naturellement on est là pour les pour
les aider mais je préfère le voir le
plus tard possible pour les alicaments
est bien ou pas bien la part dont les
alicaments les alicaments par exemple
les parisiens mais l'alimentation en
l'occurrence c'est le premier médicament
et puis la cigarette si on pouvait
trouver de 2 bat d'éviter de fumer pas
en vacances et de prendre de bonnes
résolutions pour les vacances voilà
l'alimentation la cigarette la santé
pour ma part c'est voir souhait vous oui
alors je crois que c'est à peu près le
même en fait que celui que j'avais
formulée pour la nouvelle année
c'est ce qu'on réfléchisse plus tous
ensemble parce que pour en fait quand
j'entends florence dire ça je me suis
dit ah mince et tous et c'est dommage en
fait que ça et dans cette forme de
revendications derrière moi j'avais
l'impression par rapport à un charlie
justement que on avait éviter les
amalgames
j'avais vraiment peur qu'on vire là
dedans j'ai l'impression qu'au final de
ce côté là on a évité la casse mais par
contre il est vrai la voyez il ya
bientôt le 14 juillet c'est la première
fois de ma vie j'ai défilé quand même le
14 donc j'aurais pu me poser la question
à l'époque mais pour autant non c'est la
première fois où je me dis j'espère
qu'il va rien se passer
donc je pense que le terreau
mais c'est une vraie question je me suis
souvent dit que ça n'arrive qu'aux états
unis c'est la première fois que je
prends conscience que ça peut réellement
arrivé en france et réfléchissons pour
justement ne pas alimenter daraîche et
boko haram réfléchissons pour essayer de
comprendre le bien-fondé des choses
telles qu'elles devraient être
réfléchissons pour ne pas qu'il est
inutile mans mais davantage essayer de
comprendre où l'autre est allé dans ce
sens là donc c'est toujours la même
chose florence c'est beau c'est beau
spectacle
que dire de plus après ça ce sont les
valeurs essentielles
moi je vais quand même donné mais seront
j'espère qu'il y aura un accord avec la
grèce c'est à dire un accord avec l'iran
parce que c'est vraiment extrêmement
c'est un dossier important on n'en parle
pas beaucoup parce qu'on est la grèce
qui est beaucoup d'actualité en ce
moment mais le dossier de l'iran est
important parce que c'est implicite à
des mots clés pour le bon dieu c'est un
battant donc j'espère qu'il y aura une
solution people que à la rentrée on
retrouve un petit peu de croissance est
un peu moins de chômage ces femmes bon
sens mais mes choix cf1 c'est agir local
penser global jeu moi j'espère que les
gens vont profiter de ses vacances pour
se parler entre eux pour lire pour
éteindre leur télévision donc pas que ce
soit pas bien mais il ya tellement de
belles choses dans les livres et puis
mon souhait c'est de retrouver en
septembre une université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines en
pleine forme on a beaucoup travaillé au
cours de cette année vont visiter
mieux elle nous intégrons paris saclay
donc voila moi je suis très optimiste
enfin d'accord avec stéphane clienti
faut il faudrait dire oui
donc non on a des tonnes de bonnes
choses à lire il ya à mort le chat est
un polar dire on dirait un scénario face
et tarantino devrait faire le film en
fait donc ça c'est vraiment l'écriture
très très original très méritant très
lisible très fluide mais un roman qui se
lit à 250 à l'heure donc après on peut
en lire d'autres et alors pour moustapha
niasse avait parlé dernière fois en main
propre histoire d'un clerc de notaire
algérien le client d'origine algérienne
qui est d aller donc ça s'est très très
bien pas pour vous il ya replay avec eux
ce que ce type qui veut transformer
tarbes et la région de tarbes un bled du
midwest américain donc çà çà çà çà c'est
très bien et vient l'afflux d'offres
et puis il voilà c'est très très bien et
puis dernière sous abri mon souhait mon
souhait c'est qu'on arrive enfin à
vendre les deux mistral qu'on n'a pas
voulu vendre à poutine mais parce que
c'est beaucoup d'argent
bah oui on and on a 2 2 bâtiments
énormes je cherchais impatient de faire
j'ai appris la semaine dernière qu'ils
étaient brise-glace de surprendre servir
tout cas c'est énormément d'argent celle
ci on parle de plus d'un milliard
d'euros
elle est vraiment acquis une petite
piste sur le canada attribué j'ai cru
entendre parler ça mais l'armée manquera
fonctionne très bien nous qui le faisons
donc c'est un peu dommage enfin faire la
turquie tout de suite merci si beaucoup
à pessac
voilà bah c'était la dernière émission
de cette saison j'espère qu'on se
retrouvera pour septembre pour moi je
rentrais quand même c'est qu'on se
retrouve à la rentrée va alors très vite
d'accord entre nous si le meilleur merci
merci à tous pas fait permis des bonnes
vacances à tous et donc on se retrouve
avec grand plaisir en septembre